هل تعرف ماذا تفعل إذا
سقط شخص ما في الاستوديو إذا نزل شخص ما في المنزل
وثلاثة أرباع الاعتقالات خارج
المستشفى تحدث بالفعل في المنزل ،
لذلك عادةً ما يكون أحد أفراد أسرتك
صديقًا وزميلًا في العمل نعرفه بشكل عام
هناك حوالي 350
ألف حالة من حالات السكتة القلبية المفاجئة في المستشفيات
سنويًا ، والبقاء على قيد الحياة منخفض جدًا ،
حيث يبقى حوالي 1 من كل 10 على قيد الحياة ، ولكن
مع الإنعاش القلبي الرئوي المتفرج ، يمكنك زيادة
فرص شخص ما في البقاء على قيد الحياة بحوالي
مرتين إلى ثلاث مرات وفي الواقع كل
دقيقة تمر  أنك لا
تستعيد نبضات قلبك ، تنخفض فرصها في
البقاء على قيد الحياة بحوالي سبعة إلى عشرة
بالمائة ، لذا إذا رأيت شخصًا ينزل
أولاً ، فأنت تريد التأكد من أن
المشهد آمن ، الخطوة التالية هي
الاتصال بالرقم 9-1-1 حقًا  ثم
ستدفع بقوة وبسرعة في
منتصف الصدر ، وبالتالي فإن أفضل طريقة للقيام بذلك
هي أن تأخذ راحة يدك
وتضعها هنا بين مكان الحلمات
ولكن اليد الأخرى على المرفقين المقفلين
على الكتفين.  وأنت ذاهب إلى  اضغط
بقوة لأسفل وبسرعة ، فأنت تضغط لأسفل
لضغط الصدر بحوالي بوصتين ،
لذا فهذه كمية كبيرة من القوة
التي تبذلها بقوة
أكبر مما تعتقد ،
وستفعل ذلك بمعدل  حوالي 100 إلى 120
نبضة في الدقيقة ، لذلك نتحدث عن
التفكير في الأغاني لمساعدتك على
الحفاظ على الإيقاع. تمتلك جمعية القلب الأمريكية
قائمة تشغيل تسمى لا
تسقط الإيقاع ، واحدة من الأغاني الكلاسيكية
هي البقاء على قيد الحياة على الشاطئ تبدو
غريبة ولكن  هذا صحيح
، أعني أنني لست مغنيًا جيدًا ، لكن
هذا هو بالضبط ما ينبض في الدقيقة
بالضبط وهذا ما تريد الاحتفاظ به
في رأسك ، لذا فهذه طريقة رائعة ،
لذا ستفعل CPR 911 باليد فقط
يتم استدعاؤك ومن ثم من الواضح أنه إذا كان
لديك وصول إلى جهاز إزالة رجفان القلب ،
فهذا أمر رائع حقًا أن يتوفر لديك
أيضًا والكثير من الناس لا يخافون
مما هو موجود في المربع الأزرق ، فهم لا يعرفون
كيفية تطبيقه مرة أخرى.
استخدام مزيل الرجفان في الإعدادات الصحيحة ،
إنه أمر بسيط للغاية لذا فهو هاتف  إذا
قمت بتشغيله ، فسوف تضغط على الزر
وتشغيله ، حسنًا ، ستخرج
الوسادات وتبدو أنها أجهزة iPad ، فهي توضح
لك مكان وضع الوسادات ، لذا
هنا تظهر لك هذه اللوحة التي تظهر لك
أين ستضع هذه اللوحة ، فأنت ستقوم بتوصيل
هذا
في موصل المكون الإضافي ، حسنًا ، لذا لا
أعرف ما إذا كنت تريد مساعدتي في توصيل ذلك
ومن ثم بشكل
أساسي ستقوم بتحليل إيقاع القلب
إذا اكتشف إيقاعًا  تخبرك الصدمة
أنك لا تلمس المريض
أنه سيحدث صدمة ، حسنًا ، إنه يعرف
ما يجب فعله ، لذا
ستضغط على الزر الذي يدفع
الجميع إلى البقاء بعيدًا عن المريض
، أعني حرفيًا أنه يمشي معك
في كل خطوة
[  الموسيقى] تم
تسليم مخزون الخشخاش بشكل صحيح ،
بمجرد أن تبدأ الصدمات التي تم تسليمها في
عملية الإنعاش القلبي الرئوي ، ستعود إلى إعطاء الإنعاش القلبي الرئوي
الذي تفعله لمدة دقيقتين ، ثم
يقوم بتحليل الإيقاع مرة أخرى ،
لذلك أريد فقط أن يترك الناس الفوط
نعم وهذا  يجب أن يذهب على
صدره العاري بشكل صحيح  ملابس شخص ما
تريد خلعها ولكن هذا
سهل للغاية لذا يجب ألا يخاف
الناس ولا تخافوا من إعطاء الإنعاش القلبي الرئوي للأيدي فقط
ولا تخافوا من استخدام جهاز تنظيم ضربات القلب ،
يمكنك إنقاذ حياة
الأطفال وللأطفال  إصبعين نعم